et pour parler de la situation en
afrique du sud nous sommes avec et
richard cojean président de
l'organisation médicale alima bonjour
richard cojean merci d'être avec nous ce
midi sur rt france alors on l'a dit une
population africaine jeunes des mesures
qui ont été prises assez rapidement ce
sont les explications aujourd'hui pour
un continent africain peut toucher par
le coguic 19 bonjour merci un bon ça
c'est sont des essais d'explication je
pense que ce sont des excès des essais
d'explication comme un come back comme
l'affirmé le ms et nous pensons qu'au
délà des ça il faut faire vraiment de la
recherche pour objectiver tout cela
parce que vous savez de tous ces
arguments c'est c'est c'est possible
mais vous savez l'apanage la jeunesse la
population je ne n'ai pas que l'apanage
de la région africains savent et au
brésil
si je suis pas mal des jeunes vivre à
l'extérieur vous savez dans certaines
régions de l'afrique si je prends par
exemple et les salles ni sahel-sahara
les populations il ya une bonne partie
de l'année il fait tellement chaud les
gens soient à l'intérieur il faut se
mettre à l'ombre
après il ya les périodes et vent il ya
des périodes de tempête il ya des
périodes inondations les gens sont aussi
à l'intérieur
donc là je voulais juste dire que ça ce
sont des essais d'explication et il faut
mettre des études il faut il faut
l'encourager des études pour aller
audelà des confirmés objectivement ses
arguments c'est ça notre avis le
gouvello gouvernements africains ont
pris les bonnes décisions au bon moment
les décisions ont été prises mais
regarder derrière et ce qu'elles ont été
respectées je prendrai pour exemple
maintenant notre nos régions
d'intervention je prends des villes
comme kinshasa g prendre des grandes
villes les mesures ont été prises mais
n'ont pas du tout été respectées et et
et l'afrique isolé mais je ne pense pas
l'afrique n'est pas du tout isolé il
faut voir le flux des asiatiques
en afrique elle les flux il n'y a pas
qu'elle est rude et l'occident en
afrique et l absolu important dé l'asie
vers l'afrique et donc j'insiste sur le
fait qu'il faut encourager qui est des
études fondamentales soient faites sur
le fait que les africains soient moins
moins meurent moins dans sur ces sources
est sûre c'était cette pandémie
j'ai peut-être aussi un essai
d'explication là dessus vous savez les
pays qui les régions qui enregistre
beaucoup plus de décès ce sont des
régions qui sont g10
je dirais s'éterniser c'est des régions
où les n ya pas mal d'infrastructures
qui ont fait qu'il l'environnement a été
stérilisés comparativement à l'afrique
sur le sahara l'afrique noire où il ya
des multitudes de vie à tant humaine on
parle de la danse de la démographie de
la population il ya une multitude des
vies animales multiplient des virus
multitude d'insectes
il en résulte des interactions entre ses
différentes vies qui pourraient faire en
sorte que l'unité de l'afrique en soit
constamment en alerte et qui peut aussi
epr est une piste mais tout ça je dis ce
sont que des pistes d'explication sur
lesquels il faut vraiment faire il ya
chili faire des études pour vous parler
finalement objectivement donc juste
justement richard cojean on rappelle à
l'afrique du sud est le pays africain le
le plus touché 1 parle quand on a un
virus
actuellement quelle différence y at-il
aujourd'hui entre l'afrique du sud et
des pays comme l'egypte ou le maroc dans
lesquels le virus reparti à la hausse au
mollet et la piste si d'explications que
je peux avancer comme cela comme parmi
tant d'autres car avancé l'om est scellé
fait que la laine les extrêmes n'ont
reçu de l'afrique c'est s'aider des
régions dans lesquelles aussi à d
agriculture intensive des
infrastructures énormes qui font que ces
cds ces régions sont aussi de plus en
plus stériliser qui font qu
comparativement à aller à l'afrique sud
sahara les multitudes des vies avec des
inserts né des interactions entre
plusieurs vies qui fait que je pense
c'est le fait c'est fait
d'infrastructures énorme à cette
stérilise l'environnement et fait que
ces populations dans ces régions-là
devient plus vulnérable si c'est une
piste encore une fois il faut faire des
recherches fondamentales encourager cela
vous avez quand je parle des recherches
dans ces régions là
avec plein d'infrastructures les
recherches la recherche sur qu'ovide
aujourd'hui il y en a des milliers et
des publications c'était il y en a tous
les jours mais comparativement à fric
sur le sahara où les étudiants n'a pas
assez et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il faut faire des études pour enfin
parler objectivement des l'impact des
qu'ovide directement sur les populations
africaines
mais rodez avant tout merci vous ruinera
les sharks aux gens d'avoir été avec
nous ce midi sur rt franc je rappelle
que vous êtes président de
l'organisation médicale alima merci
beaucoup